on universal basic income trial which
you recall was deferred at the last
meeting May I therefore ask council's
consent to do this
be with that thank you I would also like
to make members aware when speaking this
evening that they can either make use of
the Roman microphone
can somebody hold a more microphone
or if you prefer to be able to be more
visible on camera
please come forward to the table at the
front to make your speech from there so
from that table if anybody wants to
speak to an item please come to the
table and you will be seen on camera but
your voices will be recorded for the
meeting people watching the live stream
will be able to hear you from where
you're seated
um the first item is minutes and then
move to the minutes of the meeting held
on the 28th of July 2021 be taken and as
read and signed as a correct record is
that seconded seconded thank you all in
favor
aye
announcements to the leader of the
council wish to make any announcements
this evening
yeah I'm not sure does this turn on
thank you uh yes chair members will be
aware that in recent days Trafford has
become the highest area in the country
in terms of our covert infection rate
per 100 000 head of population just to
advise members
um we have spoken with all group leaders
earlier this week the council is taking
all steps that you would imagine that we
would to bring infection rates under
control the message that I have been
putting forward is very much one not to
panic yes the rates are increasing and
unfortunately we are starting to see
that move through
um different age ranges within our
population but actually the primary
cause of the spike is a significant
surge in infections in the school age
population and whilst some young people
can become ill from covid statistically
they are much less likely to be
seriously unwell as a result we will
continue to work with public health
officers take taking their advice on the
steps that we need to take but very much
a message to go out this evening to all
of our residents
we are saying not to panic but we are
also asking everybody to go back to
those basic principles of following
Public Health guidance and making sure
that they are taking sensible steps such
as regular sanitization of hands and
social distancing where appropriate
thank you chair
thank you councilor Weston do the chairs
of scrutiny committees have anything to
announce on behalf of their committees
no okay thank you
I had some three questions I advise that
four questions have been submitted for
this meeting and they have been listed
on the council website for members of
the public to view
I would ask the council to know that due
to the amount of business this evening
and the time constraints the questions
are not to be read out this evening and
that in accordance with the procedure
Rules full written answers will be
provided to the questionnaires at a
later date and these will be published
on the council website
thank you
item four and listed on the council on
the summons are changes to the green
party leadership and the consequent
consequential changes to committee
memberships is are reported to council
for information therefore can I take
these
please that they are noted
I
um councilor Jerome I'd like to speak
Council Jerome
thanks chair
I just uh wanted to quickly uh say thank
you to councilor Goggins for the work
she has done in leading Trafford greens
over the last three years
um I think it's an amazing achievement
leading a new party on the council
making our voice so here heard so
clearly and holding this Administration
constructively to account and making
such a positive difference for the
residents of the borough so I just
wanted to say thank you and I'm glad
she's re-prioritizing
um and I just also wanted to quickly
welcome councilor Wilton as my Deputy
who's also a leader in in many ways
thanks Jim
thank you councilor Jerome
item five is a petition regarding no
roads across Carrington
Moss which received 1 632 signatures in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme the petition organizer and a
chopping will be invited to speak to the
petition for five minutes
following which it will be debated by
Council for a maximum of 15 minutes
as he's agreed as the agreed practice
for petitions at council speeches are
normally limited to one member from each
of the groups and since there is only 15
minutes allowed for the debate each
group will be allowed in three minutes
and 45 seconds
following debate the debate the leader
of the council will then summarize the
council's response
if Council consents to these
Arrangements I will now invite Miss
chopping to introduce the petition are
we happy with those arrangements
everybody hi we are Miss chopping
please come forward
take a seat
thank you
thank you for shopping you have five
minutes
thank you
um I'd like to begin by explaining that
I'm actually going to be reading my five
minute presentation because I'm here not
for my uh skills or natural talent for
public speaking but as a mum of three
um as the secretary for the friends of
Carrington moss and as a resident of
Carrington Village
I'm here to speak on behalf of many
other residents and families who have
signed this petition 1 622
um we are local people and these
signatures represent a community that is
feeling voiceless and overwhelmed by
this tidal wave of development in our
area
it's challenging just keeping up with
the sheer number of planning
applications and it feels hard to be
heard above the noise and scale of
development so I thank you firstly for
the opportunity to present our petition
um I'd like to draw your attention to
three main points that we're asking for
your understanding and consideration in
the debate
we are asking for more consultation
we're asking for alternative options to
the building of Roads across Carrington
Moss
and we are asking for more consideration
of the environmental impact of this road
proposal in the wake of our climate
emergency
so firstly we are asking for a seat at
the table we actually want involvement
in the design stage of plans for our
locality
local people are feeling powerless
fearful and angry that Planning and
Development feels to be carried out
despite rather than for our community
members
thus far there has been no consultation
with the community regarding the
Strategic agenda for the Carrington
relief Road our village is Desperately
Seeking a stop to the huge number of
hgvs on the road to our village
but this proposal for the Carrington
relief Road
doesn't promise to deliver any benefits
or relief to Residents suffering with
the daily hammering of hgvs on their
houses and stress levels
the scheme objectives for this road are
not about prioritizing the Improvement
of Health well-being or basic safety of
local residents and even school children
who will be impacted the key objective
is about increasing capacity to deliver
growth
more construction more industrial
warehousing more housing and crucially
more traffic
induce traffic
so what about alternative options there
is no discussion or Prospect of any tram
connections no option or Prospect of any
train connections with new Carrington or
Partington even when there are existing
tracks in place
historic but how are we to be making
safer more sustainable transport choices
that allow us to get out of our cars
when the focus is entirely on building
more roads and with no actual commitment
to improving public transport
we want more cost-effective safer
alternative solutions that work for
everybody not a quick fix panic-built
approach driven by developers we unders
we understand that there is
excuse me there is time limited external
funding for the road which is at risk if
the scheme is not pushed through
planning now
but this rush job would end up costing
far more impermanent damage to
Irreplaceable habitats to the red-listed
birds endangered wildlife and to the
carbon capturing scope of Carrington
Moss
defensive
shopping would you like a drink of water
I would love one sorry
um
can you stop the club
for a minute
he's actually running down the stairs
for me that's very sweet okay
I know this is an important issue and it
needs uh you need to give it time so
just just relax
I'm sorry it is totally my nerves
foreign
this
is supposed friendly kind thank you
thank you so much
when you're ready very much thank you
the friends of Carrington Moss have
always driven a positive campaign
one that is fueled by a heartfelt desire
to Value protect and where where
possible improve our shared landscape
and green space of Carrington Moss our
green lung
we are not anti-development on the
contrary we are passionate about
engendering Progressive change
we want to regenerate as well as protect
these natural assets on Carrington Moss
we want to conserve not concrete over
the value of what is on our doorstep
our local environment is valued not only
by our local community but also by
professional organizations such as the
cpre Natural England and the Cheshire
and Lancashire Wildlife trusts
and their reviews of the PFE proposals
for Carrington are damning
please read them
in conclusion we ask you to please allow
us and seat at the table allow us to be
involved in shaping and improving our
locality by finding alternative options
to these proposed roads across the green
belt
there is nowhere else in Trafford where
we can restore peat to more effectively
capture carbon so our children and
grandchildren could breathe cleaner air
there is nowhere else in Trafford where
we can grow crops and alleviate surface
water risks so our descendants have
fresh food with a low carbon footprint
and residents are not fearful of
flooding every time it rains
and there's nowhere else in Trafford
where we could actually increase the
populations of red-listed birds and
endangered Wildlife so we can help
Nature's recovery increase biodiversity
and mitigate the impact of climate
change
thank you Miss chocolate
I'll let you return to you see
counselor Wright is going to respond on
behalf of the labor group counselor
Wright
thank you chair
I would like to thank everyone who has
signed a petition and for those who have
presented to council it's important that
we have a full and open debate about the
issues that affects our borrower
as members will be aware I am also the
war counselor for this development as
well as the executive member and I'm
afraid I fundamentally disagree with
this position
the issue we are grappling with here is
is sustainable development how can we
provide the social and economic
opportunities that currents and future
residents need
without sacrificing environmental assets
it's a big question and one not easily
answered by simple slogans or petitions
the council is not promoting transport
improvements that include a new road
without good reason
rather we are doing so because we want
to provide people
with what with that most fundamental of
benefits A Home of Their Own
and the prosperity and opportunity that
derives from full and secure employment
this is what we are trying to achieve in
Carrington and Partington for both now
and for the future
turning then to the two Central elements
of the petition
roads across the peat moss
we need to be clear that at present at
the present time the council is
promoting just one New Road in
Carrington the bulk of which will be
which will will be built on land within
the former petrochemical plant
the issue before us is how we best
connect between issued Road and the
Carrington spur of Banky Lane
to address this a full assessment of
route options was carried out including
the option of improving the current
alignment of the a6144
the result of this work looking at a
range of measures and benefits is that a
new route is ultimately more beneficial
than one based on the current road
this was an open objective and
professional study with no preconceived
agenda and the executive adopted the
conclusions of it
in terms of the impacts on any peat moss
that might be present high-level
investigations have been undertaken on
the peat in relation to the potential
carbon emissions due to peat soil
disturbance
from the geotechnical investigations
carried out to date a thin layer of peat
has been found in an isolated trial hole
and this of itself is insufficient to
change the overall carbon performance of
the two roots
this is also worth noting due to the
depth of the peak found and with the
current vertical alignment assumptions
for the roots the piece is not expected
to be disturbed let alone removed
a full environmental scoping report will
be prepared for the planning application
which is the appropriate stage for this
detailed assessment and Natural England
will be consulted as part of this
process
there is an inherent inconsistency at
the heart of this petition
on the one hand the petition says that
we don't want any rows to be built had
engaged into the rest of Trafford and
that roads promote pollution and enhance
carbon emissions
yet on the other hand it says that it is
acceptable to build roads westwards
towards Salford
and that travel in the direction and and
that travel in that direction all the
carbon emissions connected with such a
feat of infrastructure somehow don't
count
bear with me sorry
such a stamp such a stance is not
credible
these are complex issues and they
require a mature response
at the outset it is important to stress
that the Carrington relief load is but
one part of a series of Transport
measures planned for the area
the relief Road will itself provide safe
cycling to the rest of Trafford for the
first time
and when combined with GM wide reform
facilitate swifter links by boss that
most under underrated mode of public
transport
but the road on its own will never be
announced at the transport challenges of
the area
we subscribe to the tfgm 2040 transport
strategy that makes it clear that
fundamental change in the way we travel
is vital for future movements in the
city region this aims to improve trump
our transport system so that we can
reduce car use from 61 to 50 of daily
trips or less right you need to draw to
a conclusion
oh uh okay bear with me
um
for Carrington we are proposing the
ReUse of the formal rail Corridor for
green travel so we can better Link in
with the adjacent areas of Trafford and
the Metrolink Network in the other
direction we are in discussion with
Salford city council over the use of the
caddy said viaducts and links to Earlham
station
such a bridge could complement plan
transporting improvements but cannot be
viewed as a substitute for them this is
why we are taking the responsible
approach of tackling transport problems
here and now and a link road is a vital
component in our plan Suite of
improvements thank you thank you chair
thank you councilor Wright
councilor Evans likes to respond on
behalf of a conservative group
thank you mayor and I'd like firstly I'd
like to thank uh Miss chopping for her
presentation tonight and the efforts of
the whole group friends of Carrington
Moss for Gathering so many signatures
and the signatures themselves for
thinking that would actually have an
opportunity to present here tonight so
thank you for the efforts there I'd also
like to thank friends accounting to Moss
for their presentation to our group I'm
going to keep this really brief because
we have rehearsed this debate so many
times in this chain well it's not this
chamber but in this chamber and there is
no doubt we need better access to those
areas we have
um multiple homes planned and we need to
come up with a solution
but we will later discuss how we will
Empower traffic to take climate action
this certainly isn't climate action
there are alternatives to this road they
have been explored in new over numerous
years and this Council should be bold
and perhaps imagine reinstating the Moss
and coming up with a different solution
this is an old solution for a bygone
time to be frank we need to embrace the
opportunity of this Moss embrace the
area come up with a different solution
but please don't dig up three meters of
Pete thank you thank you councilor Evans
I invite counselor new gross to respond
on behalf liberal Democrat group
the last time we met
councilors spoke elegantly and
emotionally of the need for improved
connections
the labor executive are proposing this
need to be met by a new Road
a road currently destined to drive
through a moss one I'm informed is in
part three meters deep
this petition signed by a truly massive
1 632 local residents
speaks in one voice that this new road
is not the correct solution
I know the rail track spoken of by Mr
Chopin it connects timpally to
Carrington and onwards to Liverpool
there are still existent tracks of this
Railway on the timpley side
all of Trafford would benefit for the
reinstatement of this Railway
truly sustainable development
and connecting much needed areas of
Trafford
both to Liverpool and onwards
if improved roadlinks are needed to
remove the hgvs and haulage from the
area the bridge proposed to the West in
the 2012 core strategy works for a more
elegant and ecological and stainable
solution than a road over Moss
I can only commend this as the solution
joint with a railway
I also recommend the conservatives with
their new green coats on who themselves
provose something similar in 2017.
but it's nice to have them on this side
of the argument now
so I would like to speak and support
this
um
petition and I hope that people will
vote for it thank you
thank you councilor newgrash and
councilor Jerome would like to respond
on behalf of the Green Party
oh councilor Coggins is going to respond
thank you
chopping chopping here
thank you mayor um and I wanted to start
by thanking Miss chopping for her
passionate speech and there to thank the
indomitable friends of Carrington master
all that they have done on this and Miss
Joplin spoke clearly about the lack of
consultation the feeling that the
residents have that they have not been
heard that their wishes have not been
listened to I wanted to tackle four of
the other issues associated with this
road
um we have four big problems to look at
we have biodiversity loss in the face of
the sixth mass extinction in one of our
um rarest and wildest green spaces here
in Trafford and we have the carbon
emissions and air pollution from the
many extra cars and trucks that this new
road will invite over the money next
decades not just not just years we have
the Lost carbon sequestration
opportunities from building over a
degraded Wetland rather than doing
everything we can to fight to get it
restored and then finally we have the
potential health and well-being impacts
lost by increasing our car dependence
um at a time when we know that we can do
so much better and they're Carrington
and Partington are struggling I really
acknowledge that they're struggling with
congestion and with really poor
transport options and we really agree
that these need to be challenged
that these need to be tackled
um but we do actually know how to tackle
these things we know how to reduce
traffic how to improve people's
transport options how to reduce air
pollution and carbon emissions these can
all be done by bringing in measures
which make it safe cheap Pleasant and
easy for people to use other modes of
transport
now we also know that building New Roads
simply doesn't work it's been known for
decades that New Roads literally invite
more people to drive on them other
people have mentioned induced demand
tonight any decreases in congestion
generally are extremely short-lived
as new people choose to drive by car on
this route because it's an easier option
in the short term
and this isn't an opinion it's well
known and now it was of course possible
but unlikely that this would be one of
the very small number of New Roads that
this didn't happen to
um and so we did ask get exec about what
modeling had been done to show us that
usage would not lead to more congestion
over uh the next one two five ten twenty
years and there has been no modeling
done on this so really we have no real
reason to believe that this will reduce
congestion or any of the problems that
we're facing in the medium to long term
but there are many things this Council
can do there are many things within the
power of this Council to increase Road
Safety reduce congestion clean our air
and support residents to live healthier
lives we could bring in 20 mile per hour
default speed limits on our roads
throughout residential areas we could
bring in many more low traffic
neighborhoods decent direct cycle route
along the a56 and other key roads we
could expedite the introduction of a car
club and popular measures like School
streets initiatives these could all be
focused around Carrington and Partington
initially if that's felt so that's where
the where the greatest need is
so the new plan for current the plan for
a new road across Carrington Moss it
does fit really beside the council's
other greatest hits in the climate world
of doubling the airport use over the
next 20 years and continuing to invest
hundreds of millions of our Pension
funds in fossil fuel giants like shell
and BP sadly the nice words and minor
tweaks that we're doing in other areas
of tackling the climate and ecological
crises
and have have very little impact in
comparison to the damage we're doing
with these things in the run up to cup
26 it's hard to believe that we believe
that the council believes we can safely
build New Roads instead of restoring our
precious Wetlands thank you
thank you councilor Coggins
the leader asked the leader of the
council now to summarize for the council
and our guest this evening what will
happen now with the petition
thank you chair and thank you as others
have said for bringing this petition Ms
Chopin it is clearly a significant issue
that is controversial in our communities
but what I do need to say chair is that
the labor group have been extremely
consistent in our position on this
matter and I've heard both the
petitioner and indeed some of our party
spokespeople this evening setting out
reasons why this is the wrong thing to
do but I heard also counselor writing an
extremely compelling way to set out why
this road is needed if I may counselor
right as a counselor representing
Partington I think in some ways you
wonder did
the transformative impact that we see
this relief Road having on that
community and more than any other chair
that is the fundamental reason why I
have to say we hear what the petitioners
have to say but I think that we are
still taking the right course of action
as a council because we've just heard
from councilor Coggins a Litany of
measures that we could take around low
traffic neighborhoods around 20 mile per
hour zones around a cycle Lane on the
a56 no less none of this would help
connectivity for the people of
Partington or indeed Carrington and we
heard at the last executive meeting
unfortunately I couldn't be their chair
but I had heard this story previously
from councilor Slater talking about her
late mother who was delayed in getting
to hospital because of the poor
infrastructure in this area a disused
train line barely fit for purpose would
not solve that problem
the facts of the matter are these the
socio and economic statuses of the
people of Partington have been held back
for too long by appalling transport
infrastructure the conservative group
used to know this but as with so many
others of the things that they used to
believe in have casually forgotten it
with their move to opposition
but what I would say in summing up Mr
Mary's we know that this will have a
major impact on our communities we
accept that it will be controversial we
don't hide from the fact that there will
be an environmental impact but the right
to a good quality job the right to a
safe and warm home these are my
priorities as the leader of this Council
chair and whilst we will mitigate as
best we can they will always be my
priorities thank you chair
thank you councilor Weston
it's Chopin you're welcome to stay with
your colleagues for the rest of the
meeting but uh
you might want to
bid us farewell
thank you for coming this evening
item six is a report of the deputy chief
executive concerning the salary and
benefits package for the director of
Public Health and I invite the leader
councilor Weston to introduce the item
and move the recommendations councilor
Western
thank you chair members will be aware
without me going into any significant
detail of the very exceptional
circumstances in which the council has
had to operate over the past 18 months
chair and one of the direct implications
of this is that we have been required to
call upon our public health staff
days a week and indeed outside of what
one may consider reasonable hours over
the past 18 months in doing so with
reference to our director of Public
Health usually paid just below the 100
000 pounds level at which we would need
to report to council we had determined
that given the amount of work required
of her because of the specialist nature
of her role and because of the need to
be able to draw upon that advice at all
times that we would pay her an
additional 250 pounds per month during
the period that we have been fighting
the pandemic this has taken our director
of Public Health for the preceding
Municipal year 612 pounds 50 over the
100 000 pound reporting level my view on
this chair is very clear it is obviously
a temporary measure it is obviously an
exceptional measure and it is obviously
in my view an understandable measure so
I hope all members will feel able to
support thanks chair thank you councilor
Weston is that second did councilor Ross
any members wishing to speak
Council Jerome please
um we just wanted to um thank the
director of Public Health for the work
that she's been doing during the
pandemic um it's really
um
been excellent work throughout that
period but we just wanted to know when
this came to light
um and why wasn't it reported to
councils sooner
to vote on thank you thank you anybody
like to respond
yeah I'm afraid I don't know the actual
reason why this didn't come to light
earlier councilor Jerome we can
certainly look into that and come back
to you
um on that I think to be honest it may
be and I and I could be speaking for
offices unfairly here that given the
Breakneck speed at which we've had to
operate and make these decisions over
the past 18 months that it slipped
through the net that it triggered the um
100 000 pound threshold particularly
because it was not a straightforward
uplift to salary but rather a monthly
increase so so I will look into the
specific reasons why if we need to we
can look at some measures where this is
auto flagged in a way that I think
Perhaps it is
um when people move over that in their
standard salary but by the same token I
would like to assure all members that
we're not in the habit of paying
um additional monthly payments as
standard so it may be some time before
we have a similar occurrence thank you
chat thank you councilor Western anybody
else wish to comment
no okay the report has been moved and
seconded can I ask if the council
consents would you like me to put this
to a vote
I'm happy with the consent can we hear
an eye yes hi thank you
item seven and a report of the executive
member for environmental and Regulatory
services on minimum licensing standards
for taxis and private hire has been
recommended to the council by the
executive
on the 20th of 2021
and I invite councilor adzed to
introduce and move the item councilor ad
said
that's marvelous
I think I've just stopped off a little
bit so
I might have lost my page so much for
I.T
hopefully
come back on one second
what's that right thank you thank you
yes uh the report before was on minimum
license standards it's obviously an
extremely important one and obviously I
won not the council's been keen on for
many years now
certainly speaking to colleagues which
is some licensing I know it's sort of
long overdue and indeed speaking with
people colleagues and other people from
across greater Manchester they're also
very supportive or something like this
that I think one of the things that's
quite clear from the report it's a Taxis
and private houses are you very very
unique in their service in their really
local contact with that with those
people in such a in in the environment
which they use obviously on one-to-ones
and so forth so it's actually an
extremely vulnerable position for people
who actually have to use it and
potentially it's only correct that we
therefore have measures in place that so
when somebody books a taxi or private
hire they know that the drivers have
actually been through the device
checking system and and that therefore
that not only the will the vehicle be
standards but the driver will be trained
not just in actually how to behave and
dress and so forth we think we're all
acceptable also that of an awareness
training of many of those things so I
think it's really really important but a
really good discussion about this that's
executive and those cross-party support
for that so in that sense of it I think
I was really pleased that I would also
add at this point it's obviously not the
end of the day apart from we'll have uh
the next section of license standards at
the future executive near future I think
also this will actually be as it goes on
over the next two years I think there
may be certainly further discussions
around how we can improve that assuming
one of the areas that I know is a big
concern is that what I think they call
Out of Towners and and that's a real
concern and it's something that I think
all members have actually flagged up and
actually are concerned about and it's
one that we obviously take Debbie
seriously and in that sense of it we
will continue to put pressure uh both
locally and regionally I know something
that Andy Burnham's office is very
concerned about us all and we'll
continue to put pressure through them
and if necessary other bodies to
government to try and get this corrected
now we have all parties support for that
but something that we feel very strongly
about and as I said it is active the one
thing that when someone's booking a
service and they should actually make
sure they actually ask for a Trafford or
indeed a GM registered taxi or private
hire so they normally are registered
local I think we do need to do some
comms around that possible as this moves
forward so people are aware of this and
actually how to make sure that happens
so with that I'll actually leave that
and actually wait for any questions if
do I have any thank you thank you
councilor I'd said is that seconded
second itcher thank you councilor Weston
any members wishing to speak
Council Jerome yes
thanks chair
um traffic greens welcome uh this it's a
it's a great move in standardizing the
the taxi service throughout the borough
and when when I was on public protection
in my first year as a counselor they do
ask you
um would you find it safe to have your
your own children in this taxi and I
think these measures will certainly make
people feel safer about getting into
taxis and have having a good onward
Journey
um one thing I did want to ask which uh
came from my partner actually she did
ask if if uh GM taxis will clearly
display that they are GM taxis more
clearly
um so people know that they're getting
into a safe taxi where standards are
applied a high degree but um yeah
traffic Green's very much welcome and
we'll support this thank you chair thank
you councilor Jerome would you like to
respond counselor I said
obviously uh I think yeah we have
actually talked about and I believe that
it's referred to as a what maybe a
common uh Livery uh although I think
they'll be in the same sort of place but
maybe I don't it will obviously display
traffic but it will be common in that
sense so it should be what I think
that's coming next month actually or the
month after when we actually look at
vehicle standards so if we look out for
it there but certainly something that
has been talked about and I certainly
would agree that sort of recognize sort
of lively where it's going to be and so
forth would actually be something that
we could all support and get behind
thank you thank you councilor chairman
you'd like to speak
foreign
I'd like to welcome this report
um
it's it's obviously work done by the The
Joint greater Manchester licensing
authorities
uh working towards minimum standards
across the authorities to improve safety
reliability and quality of service
so as Steve has said this is stage one
of the of the recommendations covering
uh drivers and and operators
stage two which I believe is is coming
either next month or December perhaps
he's covering the vehicles
and we'll include uh standard Livery
which may be controversial not least
amongst the trade
and also zero working towards zero
emissions standards
um so so these these proposals do follow
an extensive consultation with the
public and the taxi trade at the back
end of last year
so this is trafford's contribution to
the Geo minimum standards because all
the licensing authorities are autonomous
so they're all responsible for their own
their own standards so
these proposals have been to the public
protection committee for comment they've
obviously been to the exact for approval
and it doesn't hopefully seem to be
controversial so I hope we would we
would I would recommend that that we all
approve it tonight thank you thank you
councilor German councilor Blackburn
thank you Mr Mayor we support minimum
licensing standards across greater
Manchester
um but regarding
um the caseary report that's shown on
their page 26. first sentence uh Casey
report made it clear that we can in
effective arrangements for taxi and
private high licensing had left children
and the public at risk the last sentence
it's with Public Safety in mind that our
primary Duty as licensing authorities
that the MLS are proposed
um as councilor as had mentioned there
are many out of Greater Manchester uh
Borough
drivers and I think we still have great
concerns that if if any drivers do
anything that is inappropriate or
illegal that we don't have any authority
to deal with them
um just going back or going forward on
sorry onto page 33.
with uh regard to sorry
papers here sorry with regards to
standard six uh it's proposed that all
authorities require drivers to undertake
training of the following areas
safeguarding child sexual exploitation
human trafficking trafficking and county
lines disability and dementia awareness
and licensing law could I ask
um how often do drivers need to take
this training or how often is it
proposed If a driver refuses to
undertake the training will they be
refused their badge If a driver is
registered in an authority outside of GM
will we inform the said authority of
their refusal
um and I'm speaking about the the
safeguarding of of our children which we
all put as a priority thank you thank
you councilor Blackburn councilor I said
would you like to respond
thank you it's up to the debate or to
that question uh well I think Council
Blackburn's asking about standard six
how it will be implemented
uh thank you yes
six yeah I mean uh yeah I mean uh one of
the things that we'll try and get some
further information I'm not quite sure
how some of it relates it but I would
imagine that uh if a driver who was
being trafficked registered uh refused
to take it then they won't be issued
with a license if they don't simply
fulfill that uh what it sits like
without a town as as we want to call
them I'm not completely sure in that
sense obviously if anything is reported
obviously it will be taken action it
would be reported back I think that's
something we can take but can actually
have a look at I think that that the
it's quite clear when you look at the uh
the uh well the training sessions and
I've seen the log where everything's
recorded on it uh that then they have to
take part and it's only as they proceed
from one stage to the next uh well you
have to pass certain things to move to
the next stage and then completed it
then they don't get a license so all
that training would be in there and it
is actually a mandatory for them to do
that but you're quite right where it's
Out of Towners I'm not completely clear
how that applies to in that sense
because obviously the license isn't
issued by us so and I think that's a
problem I refer to earlier but certainly
when we take seriously and I can
obviously say obviously that if any news
report should we do need to take action
on that and it would certainly be
reported back but I'm not clear how much
Powers we've got but certainly is there
anything appropriate obviously it'd be a
matter for the police as well anything
that would take forever and it makes the
case much stronger as in cases earlier
that we've really got to get uh Changed
by a government to actually make sure
that the south of town was really it
needs to come into an end in this day
and age so that people can know
something we take very seriously I think
certainly the protection of it is at the
heart of this this is the whole point of
this it's that protection to anybody
who's potentially vulnerable or
something like you know and that isn't
just children it can be a whole range of
people with learning disabilities and
anything you know older people uh people
with dementia anything like that there's
all sorts of people and they're
basically that they're putting basically
like their lives in the hands of this
journey taking place and I think it's
only right that they do actually be able
to know that that is reliable that's the
whole point of this service and I think
it is uh retrograde obviously that we
can't have the control we want when
they're Out of Towners it's certainly
something that this Council will be
discussing more there's no doubt both at
local level and at GM level it's
something that we remain very concerned
about and I think certainly this debate
will very much continue but I'll discuss
those points further and get any further
information that we will get back to you
thank you thank you councilor I said
councilor Freeman
I just want to share councilor
Blackburn's concerns but point out to
her that the out of town taxi situation
really requires government legislation
to put it to an end and I can I spent
two years nearly three years as
opposition spokesperson for licensing on
this Council it was raised time and
again both through the LGA and both and
and nationally and your government has
decided it is not on their agenda so go
and Lobby Graham uh it's a Graham Brady
go on Lobby all your all your MPS to get
this issue sorted because certainly we
want our public in this Borough to use
properly licensed taxes license within
greater Manchester but as per these
standards to ensure that they're safe to
travel and you cannot guarantee that
with the out of town is who we have
absolutely no authority over so let's
all Lobby national government to get it
on the their agenda to get something
done about it thank you mayor
thank you councilor Freeman
um anybody else wishing to speak
the report has been moved and seconded
can it be agreed very quickly mention
one thing before in summing up there for
half a minute absolutely
um just comment because obviously we had
a council jam and theme and comment so
obviously uh obviously Echo everything
completely that uh councilor Seaman has
said and it's and I think certainly we
should be continued and hope that
conservative group and others will
actually Lobby their government to do
that they should be in a strong position
to do that I think it's certainly
something that we'll be doing through
the gems through the gmca and indeed
throughout through the LDC we certainly
certainly something that we wanted to
continue but we need that support from
everybody to do that that's obviously
it's something that I said will continue
to be on the agent and we discussed it
will certainly not be dropped exactly
and just another quickly to cancel jam
and obviously public consultation when
you read through the report is actually
quite clear I think it's something like
94 uh with public take up on that that
behind it so I think that's actually
Debbie telling that almost all publicly
racist it actually the biggest part of
the consent of the day so it's something
that the public across that the whole of
GM really feel very strongly about so I
think it's certainly something that
we're doing the right thing and
obviously I thank everybody for their
supporters and hopefully as I said it
isn't just this is not the end of the
process I think really it's just the
next stage in it there and obviously
there's also a lot more work to do over
the next few years to continue to make
this that as part of a trans which is
what it is it is part of our public
transport system and it's one that needs
to be make sure it's to account and make
sure it's at the heart of things that we
do so everybody remains safe thank you
thank you thank you councilor I've said
the report has been moved and seconded
can it be agreed please or would you
like me to put this to a vote
hi
thank you item eight this evening six
motions have been listed on the summons
in the order that they were received
the first the witched on universal basic
income has now been withdrawn
to get through the business and to give
everyone who wants an opportunity to
speak it may be necessary to limit the
time for speeches
motion 8B proceeding with the second
motion concerning Hong kongers in
Trafford set out at HB I have received
notice that that is to be moved by
councilor newgrush Council newgrush
please thank you so just to set the
scene this motion was written before the
fall of Afghanistan I did consent
consider amending my own emotion
to be more inclusive to reflect the
rapidly changing world events and I
thank the executive for their friendly
amendment to that effect
this evening I'm speaking to the motion
submitted but be aware it is more
inclusive than this
so thank you mayor the purpose of this
motion is to ensure that this Council
extends the warmest possible welcome to
all newcomers of Trafford with a focus
on Hong kongers the decision to uproot
your life your family from everything
you have known to begin again in a new
country is a hugely difficult one
even when it is not set to a backdrop of
attacks on Democratic freedoms civil
deliverities and your own culture
I know that colleagues and counselors
from all parties will be very proud that
so many Hong kongers are choosing to
start a new chapter for themselves and
their families here in Trafford a new
home a new start where they are very
welcome
liberal Democrat counselors have been
meeting with newly settled on Congers in
Trafford for some time now and I know
that other Council groups have had
similar meetings hope and optimism has
been a running theme throughout that
dialogue
but Hong kongers similar to newcomers
from around the world do face challenges
here and this Council can and must do
more to help
we are rightly proud of our excellent
schools in Trafford and it is this sharp
increase in demand on schoolplaces that
is one of my main concerns
a concern that requires us to work
together with schools and parents to
find the school places that are required
School placements especially in this
instance should not become a party
political issue
it's right also that we strive to be
inclusive this motion commits us to use
Cantonese where possible to enable
families to have access to Vital
Information crucially on areas such as
educational need
integration is so important to Hong
kongers and Britain so many of them feel
a close Affinity with this country one
that is a values based and is deeply
held
as local councilors we can really help
with that on a day-to-day basis
residents tell us that as newcomers they
can often feel isolated or restricted
unable to Branch out into the community
often held back while balancing the
daily errands of cat Child Care job
hunting all the pressures of a new job
all this while navigating a foreign
country using a new language and without
the Family Support Network or local
know-how that they had in their former
home
all of us here know and are connected to
a wide range of local groups clubs and
societies and our Wards and across
Trafford we have a responsibility to
help enable those connections be made
where we can
by supporting this motion tonight you'll
be sending a positive inclusive message
to Hong kongers now and in the future
that this Council will work proactively
with you as a community and as
individuals
if you come to Trafford you can rely on
us to make you welcome listen to your
concerns and work hard on your behalf
I hope that all councils across the
political Spectrum can unite in
supporting this motion thank you thank
you councilor new grosh is emulsion
seconded
councilor Brophy
yes I'll be seconding but I'll speak
later after the other comments have been
made
thank you councilor Brophy
I received notice of an amendment and I
will now ask for this to be moved I
understand by the leader of the council
thank you chair and firstly can I take
the opportunity to thank the liberal
Democrat group for bringing what is a
very important motion to counsel this
evening councilor newgrass alluded to
the fact that a number of different
political groups actually have been
meeting with Trafford Hong kongers I did
so actually not in my capacity as leader
of the labor group but in my capacity as
lead with the council with the acting
chief executive several weeks ago and
discussed a number of issues being
experienced by Hong kongers who have
moved to Trafford in very significant
numbers and the first thing that I would
like to say and I wanted to ring out
from this room this evening is welcome
to each and every one of them we are
delighted that they have chosen to come
to Trafford and we hope that they will
become fully embedded into our
communities in the months and years
ahead the reason for the amendment
councilor new grosh is quite right is
that the world picture has changed
somewhat since then and the council
always must be cognizant of allocating
our our resources which are finite in
accordance
um with need that said there has been a
tremendous amount of work that has
already gone on with the Hong Kong
community and the emerging and the
emergent community group Trafford Hong
kongers looking for instance at
organizing language assessments and we
are in the hundreds now in terms of
language assessments that have been
undertaken organizing conversation cafes
for Hong kongers to develop their
English language skills sharing a number
of different pieces of information with
them around
how they navigate
um becoming employed in this country
access to benefits support for elderly
people a range of different issues we
are absolutely committed as a council to
um to taking this forward and to making
sure that Hong kongers feel very welcome
here and you will note a couple of items
that have been added to the motion as a
result of the meeting that myself and
the acting chief executive had with
Trafford Hong kongers firstly and I know
I speak for all members when I say this
we absolutely in this Council condemn
any and all hate crime and it is
extremely upsetting that I heard from a
member of the Trafford Hong Congress
group that they had experienced hate
crime in Trafford but also that members
of their Community had done more widely
not thankfully in large numbers but we
must always be vigilant and always stand
against that sort of behavior as I know
the overwhelming majority of our
residents do so the other is a rather
more Niche issue but one that is having
a significant impact on our growing Hong
Kong Community here in Trafford and that
is access swiftly to National Insurance
numbers on arrival in this country two
reasons one is because people want to
find a job obviously but two is because
this particular group of people coming
to this country do not have recourse to
public funds so it is incredibly
important therefore that we do
everything that we can to expedite this
issue and we understand the reasons why
we know that there are that there are
problems with pressure in the DWP at
present in terms of allocating those
numbers but it is critically important
and so I hope in a a political way that
all members will hear the need for us to
write and raise this issue at National
level so that we can seek to get that
issue resolved for our emerging Hong
Kong community so that they can
ingratiate themselves as quickly and as
fully as possible that they can access
workplace opportunities and that they
can enjoy everything that each and every
one of us in this room want the
residents of Trafford to be able to
enjoy and so with that chair I move the
amendment thank you thank you councilor
Weston is it Amendment second dude
thank you very much any members wishing
to speak to the amendment councilor
Evans
foreign
thank you chair
um clearly the conservative group
welcome our new arrivals all our new
arrivals and we clearly welcome this
motion and the amendment for that matter
our control trolling group did engage
with the new community
and a little shop that the opposition
groups weren't invited to be frank
Rising above Petty politics in the
spirit showing the best that Trafford
has to offer in our communities
choosing to hold short meetings
together without us so however the
conservative group did embrace our new
arrivals we did meet with their
representatives our Deputy leader myself
other councilors and representatives of
similar immigrant communities met with
them
we have on their behalf approached the
ATC the scouts the guides and even the
police cadet force and are in the
process of raging an introduction of
what's available
when I arranged an introduction to the
ultimate myself West MP sir Graham Brady
who has met with them and taken up some
of their concerns we even gave them a
tour of Trafford Town Hall and as you
suggest in the amendment we have in
conjunction with sir Graham Brady
already written to the DWP regarding
National Insurance numbers to save you
the effort the response the response was
received from guy Opperman four weeks
ago and has been relayed to them his
answer was demand for the National
Insurance number service is currently
high with the average time taken to
process applications around 13 weeks
this is for all employment inspired
applications including arriving from
Hong Kong with British national overseas
status the department is currently
recruiting and training additional staff
to reduce these waiting times the
department expedites National Insurance
number applications for those who
require one in order to receive Social
Security benefits the answer was
submitted on the 20th of September and
is published on parliament's written
answers web page
we've also contacted the dvla because
there are severe delays in Hong Kong
Nationals submitting their driving
licenses and getting them back
and finally um given some difficulties
around school placements which we've
already alluded to we introduce them to
the wider education sector and we'd
ordered this Council to be inclusive in
matters such as this in future however
we totally support the motion we totally
support the amendment and we welcome our
new arrivals thank you
thank you councilor Evans
any other members wishing to speak
oh
leader yeah thank you chair I'm slightly
stunned by councilor evans's accusation
of petty politics I hold a statutory
role in this Council and I responded to
a request from Trafford Hong kongers to
meet with me
aside from anything else if you want to
talk about Petty politics you could have
shared the response to that letter
rather than bring it in an attempt to
look good in this motion debate this
evening if you want to talk about Petty
politics counselor Evans I could unleash
a Litany of examples of your recent
Behavior but my meeting as the elected
leader of this council with Trafford
Hong kongers at their request certainly
does not meet that criteria I am really
disappointed that you've chosen to
complain about that in this meeting this
evening and I hope if you are looking to
move forward in a spirit of cross party
working which you purport when it suits
you you will not raise issues as
inappropriate as that in future because
I think you know councilor Evans
although you've not been fortunate
enough to hold this role the number of
times that I was ever invited to such
meetings when your party were in control
of this Council and the number of times
that you have been invited to
cross-party meetings since I have been
leader of this Council
it is entirely unnecessary for you to
have raised that issue this evening it
cheapens your contribution to this
debate I am delighted that you and all
members are working so constructively
with Trafford Hong kongers but please
please never accuse me of cheap and
Petty politics for doing my job whilst
unleashing the very same by your
contribution thank you chair
thank you councilor Weston councilor
Jerome would like to comment
thank you chair uh just to be fairly
short but um
traffic greens would also like to extend
a warm hand to Hong kongers who have
arrived and will be coming in the near
future
um they will broaden our society they
will enrich our culture and that they
will probably add to our economic life
too
and hopefully we may even see one or two
cloggers in in the chamber at some point
too
um
so uh councilor Coggins I think actually
went to meet with Hong Kong as
um and gave them a very warm welcome but
we welcome this motion an amendment and
will wholeheartedly be supporting it
thank you thank you councilman Jerome
um councilor Minis
thank you chair
just wanted to say that I'm I'm so
touched by everybody's
um
one welcome to people coming to this
country
um my my my father came from Uganda as
Ugandan Indian
um and then when he came he then
supported others coming here and
settling
um thank you so much
thank you councilor minis
um councilor Brophy you reserved the
right do you want to speak to the
amendment
so thank you everybody just want to pay
a tribute to the work that's already
been done to welcome Hong kongers to
Trafford I think it's good that I'm
really pleased that Trafford is
extending such a warm welcome to Hong
Kong as an all-new arrivals it's um
really proud that Hong kongers are
choosing to come to Trafford proud of
our diversity here proud that Trafford
here we strive to be inclusive
I'm happy about the comments that have
been made because
um people coming to our country add
value and add to our culture just a
couple of comments about what Andrew
Weston was saying we are welcoming the
Amendments as liberal Democrats things
have changed since we submitted the
motion
and um we're pleased that you've been
welcoming and meeting Hong kongers we do
stand against hate crime here I'm glad
that there's work going on to raise
National level about Expedia you know
getting the National Insurance numbers
sorted and support councilor Jerome's
comments about how
um Hong kongers can broaden our society
in which our society and hoping that
eventually we have some Hong kongers
here in the chamber thank you for the
support from the greens and thank you
councilor minis for her personal
comments and finally just um welcoming
Hong kongers here I think it gives us
some hope for the future thank you
thank you councilor Brophy councilor
Freeman you'd like to comment
um I just want to Echo the words of the
leader of the council uh and thank the
liberal democrats for bringing the
original motion and the words of the
greens and also point out to council
that actually we had a head start here
when we appointed the schools
coordinator very early this year before
this all broke and also the English as a
second language coordinator which has
been absolutely fantastic not just for
this community but for all those across
our communities that are seeking to
retrain to reskill to find employment
and uh so I'd just like to say thank you
to everyone in the chamber for
supporting the motion and the amendment
thank you
thank you councilor Freeman so we're
still discussing the amendment councilor
newgrass you have the right to reply
he
happy okay
I'll now put the amendment to the vote
or do an I think I've got uh acceptance
from everybody can we have a an eye hi
thank you the amendment is carried thank
you since we have already had
substantial discussion I propose without
any further debate to move to the
suspense to that suspense substantive
motion
and it was other members wishing to
speak
as I say we've had quite a lot of
discussion on that
um I don't think we need to move to a
vault can I hear an affirmation from
everybody hi thank you motion 8C the
next motion this evening is regarding
climate action is to be moved by
councilor Coggins please
thank you mayor this is a positive
motion aimed at empowering residence
counselors and officers to gather
momentum behind climate's emergency and
it's got three main aims
um firstly to speed up the rate at which
you're taking action the first two
resolutions are about that
secondly to ensure that Council staff
officers and residents are empowered to
make the green choice where they choose
to and the next three resolutions are
about that
and thirdly to push government for more
support for councils to tackle the
emergency in the last two resolutions
sadly the labor Amendment removes the
first two resolutions I want to talk
about those first
and we do need a commitment to be frank
in the language we use to describe the
crisis we're in and obviously there will
be times when we need to say refer to
the climate change act or there are
specific reasons when we need to use the
word global warming or climate change
um but we do need a systematic
institutional commitment to recognizing
the emergency that we face and using
language that doesn't deny or diminish
that
I actually wrote this resolution after a
previous labor amendment to one of our
motions sought to remove the word
emergency and replace it with the
watered down version climate change
um now we have seen the mayor change the
language he's using uh to be addressed
in Council and we've also seen the
council move away from talking about uh
accidents with cars and on the road and
instead talking about crashes so we have
an acceptance and an acknowledgment that
the language we use matters and I think
it is disappointing to see a lack of
commitment to using
um the Frank and honest language that we
need here
uh the second resolution that was
deleted by labor is about learning
lessons from the pandemic and I've heard
many people including senior officers
describe and the Nimble and efficient
way that the community hubs were set up
during the pandemic
um it was actually one of our very
senior offers who suggested it to me
that we have a case study to see what
can be learned from that and moved over
into the climate crisis
um it is true that public services are
slow to change and that can be for good
reasons but this isn't one of those
times we need to learn what we can from
the one crisis that we have gone through
and apply that to the next Crisis
very briefly I'm pleased to see that
most of the other resolutions are
largely accepted and I would like some
assurance that the website changes might
happen before 2023 again if we're to
have any plausibility with saying that
this is urgent really simple stuff like
making this easy to access from the
website does not take another two years
and the other resolutions are about
ensuring the officers and residents are
empowered to choose the green option
when they can if our work for culture
for example requires a dress code that's
incompatible walking to appointments
then people feel they have no choice but
to drive if people coming to meetings in
the town hall as at the moment are not
made aware that it's right beside a tram
stop and on a reasonably safe
um cycle Lane then they might not think
of using them and so these really are
low-hanging fruit and I'm pleased to see
them being largely accepted and the last
two resolutions are about asking the
government for more support and and I
think this is where it'll be really
important to have um the support of of
the conservative group if we could
because this is about their government
and so many of the obstacles we face as
a council that we're trying to tackle
together are because we cannot act alone
and the LGA has brought a proposal for a
body to enable councils to work together
and give them a framework for tackling
the climate emergency hand in hand with
national government
uh some information this is a positive
constructive motion aiming to capture
some of the low-hanging fruit to really
accelerate our response to the climate
emergency the actions require little or
no economic costs and they will save us
money in the long term by enabling
everyone to take action rather than
relying on the council to drive
everything thank you
thank you councilor Coggins councilor
Welton you'd like to second the motion
thank you Joe
language matters when we're discussing
the climate emergency
as much for what isn't being said as
what is
how many of our residents are aware that
we need to cut our total climate
emissions by over 13 a year to meet our
targets how are they being prepared for
the Stark choices that are going to have
to be made to the way we live work and
travel if we're going to have any hope
of achieving those targets
currently the council is running scared
of telling people what it needs to hear
this motion would at least require that
the language that the council uses
conveys the seriousness of the impending
climatic and ecological disaster that we
face
unfortunately it's all too familiar that
Trafford underplays the seriousness of
the situation
we managed to launch the very very
welcome poverty truth commission last
week but we are three years on from the
climate emergency declaration and a
similar body or citizens assembly has
yet to be initiated with still only
vague problem promises that it will be
soon
yesterday I read that due to pollution
and Global Heating
within 25 years our planetary Waters May
reach a pH in which 80 to 90 percent of
Plankton will die out
deprived of the oxygen Plankton produces
we will face runaway Global Heating and
life on Earth as we know it will rapidly
become unsustainable in 25 years my
daughter will only be 35. I'm absolutely
terrified of the struggles she and her
generation will face it's time we
toughened up and started speaking the
language of Crisis and emergency with
regards to the climate and from our
language bring forth the Urgent action
that we need to take I urge you to allow
us to vote on this motion unchanged
thank you thank you councilor Welton
um I have also received notice of an
amendment this motion and invite this to
be moved by councilor Oxford councilor
Oxford
I'm moving the amendment to reflect the
changes the labor group want to make to
this motion
firstly I don't think we can equate the
climate crisis the covet crisis as the
climate crisis is far more extensive
ongoing and wide reaching needs Massive
Action far more investment to avert and
mitigate his efforts effects secondly
yes language is of course important
but it doesn't seem to be affecting the
action we need to take as Greta
Thornburg recently said to world leaders
you just offer words blah blah blah blah
blah blah that's what she said it's just
words no action
and I'm surprised the green party hasn't
suggested the use of environmental and
climate crisis or biodiversity and
climate emergency to reflect the dire
State and natural environment is in
we of course agree that climate crisis
information and action needs to be more
visible on the council website and of
course people should be encouraged to
enable
um encouraged and enabled to commute by
bike or walking
to sum up truly empowering Trafford to
take action depends on massive
government investment and political will
and I feel this most is rather
ineffectual and unambitious in its
suggestions
let's hope that Alex Sharma cop 26 wakes
up and commits to UK to tackling climate
crisis head-on acknowledges that the UK
is far behind its targets and off its
appropriate local government investment
I move the amendment
thank you councilor Oxford
um is the amendment seconded seconded
chair I'll reserve the right thank you
thank you
the amendment has been moved and
seconded do any members wish to speak to
the amendment
councilor Brophy
the microphone coming to you
okay so I'm speaking against the
amendment on behalf of the liberal
Democrat group because
um the amendment does nothing to tackle
action and I disagree with the comments
made about the effect of the amendment
so we've had covid it was scary it was
unsettling and for many it was also
life-changing we've got climate change
looming and that's going to be much more
scary and life-changing I agree with
councilor Welton about language being
important we should be talking about
climate crisis climate emergency because
only by using that kind of language will
people understand the responsibilities
we have
cop 26 is coming up it's arguably the
most important event of this Century
it's make or bake for the planet and I
like the fact the motion has brought it
right back down to earth what we can do
in Trafford what we can do to make a
difference our local choices
okay so I'm a newbie bike commuter to
work it was a difficult thing to start
with because I'm a fair weather cyclist
and to do it every day was quite
difficult but I discovered it was
actually quicker to travel by bike than
to get to the car park with into a
hospital but I also discovered that the
clothing you wear is actually important
how you feel about cycling is also
important and luckily when I get to work
I change into a uniform so people are
expected to change anyway but actually
being able to cycle into work being able
to use public transport it does require
a culture change and there are things
that traffic can do I completely agree
with the comments about the website it's
really something that should have done a
long time ago if we were using language
like climate crisis and climate
emergency perhaps we would have changed
the website already so I would like to
ask Trafford to support the Green motion
as it is on amended I think it speaks
for itself it's what we can do in
traffic but now right now to tackle this
climate emergency and this climate
crisis
thank you councilor Brophy councilor
Jerome
thanks chair I'd like to Echo the words
of councilor Brophy um and I'm surprised
by this amendment really we passed our
climate emergency in November of 2018
and now this this small motion is just
asking for the low hanging fruit and I
disagree with councilor Oxford
completely language is so important the
way we speak about a crisis it's
important that we're accurate and we get
the words right
um and we can't delay any longer and
this motion is just asking for simple
things off the back of a climate
emergency motion that was passed almost
three years ago so we should be getting
on and doing these things very quickly
and there is so much that Trafford
Council can do it's not just about
investment from the government there's
lots of things this council could be
doing to reduce our carbon emissions to
get people out of their cars to get them
walking and cycling and this Council was
being slow on all of them so I'm really
surprised by this amendment and I would
encourage members here tonight to vote
for the full motion thanks chair
thank you councilor Jerome anybody else
wish to comment
councilor Coggins you have the right
Council of Western apologies
just comes from Western Michigan
would you like to go first Council yeah
that's fine yeah thanks
chat I'm going to own up actually it's
myself that has a personal objection to
members of this Council having their
language mandated I think it's a really
important principle actually that
members are free to express themselves
in representing their residents as they
see fit and I will never support a
motion that mandates language whether I
want to ban things that I fundamentally
disagree with from the conservatives of
things that I fundamentally disagree
with from the green party I will never
support emotion that mandates what
language elected members could should
would or must use I think that is
entirely inappropriate what that does
not mean is that this Council will never
use the language of climate emergency
nobody is saying that
but I will not accept a principle that
some members can tell other members what
they can and cannot say ever and I
realize that some members think that
that is ducking our actions in tackling
the climate emergency but I
fundamentally disagree because when
councilor Jerome is saying
I'm really disappointed you're going
against this motion there's so much the
council could do that you're not I don't
think we've said
anything in that would help us tackle
the climate emergency we won't do in
this we've said that we will not support
a review into standing up covid support
hubs because we do not believe that it
correlates directly to the breadth of
the climate emergency and how we tackle
that but everything else you're asking
for around advertising ways to travel to
and from the town hall around dress code
in fact the dress code has already been
relaxed recently so there's no issue
there around the website councilor
Coggins was looking for some assurance
that the the changes to the website will
be made imminently they will be nobody
is suggesting it will be done in 2023
we've said that we will look at it as
part of our ongoing digital strategy and
we support albeit it has been reworded
writing to alok Sharma to make the
um requested representations we're more
than happy to do that but it is rating
that in demanding action you come back
to words
and I will not
cannot and never will support telling
any counselor in this chamber what they
can or cannot say and it is for that
reason chair that I take real issue with
this motion as it stands thank you thank
you councilor Western councilor Evans
thank thank you chair
um I would like to support the amendment
and I do agree that kovid does there's
no correlation between covid and the
climate emergency and uh really just
Echo the leader with respect to language
and I think there are many things this
council could be doing but those two
things really uh aren't necessary so we
will be supporting the amendment and in
due course the substantive motion thank
you councilor Evans any other members
wishing to speak no so councilor Coggins
you do have the right to reply thank you
thank you I'll deal with you of the
comments thank you um to all who've
spoken
um the motion at no point attempts to
equate the covert crisis with the
climate crisis and this proposal about
the case study came from discussions
with senior officers about the fact that
this Council sometimes moves very slowly
and sometimes more slowly than other
councils and that that is not compatible
with tackling the climate emergency in
the way that we need to do so and the
suggestion was from one of our senior
officers that actually the community
hubs and the setting up of them so
quickly and effectively is an example of
the sort of work we should be doing and
that if we could take some lessons from
that we could apply to the climate
crisis
um I'm slightly bewildered by some of
Labor's comments there is no mandating
of what anyone should say it does say
should choose it's very clear that
everyone should choose and of course if
the whole Council votes for it and then
no one is being mandated to do anything
that we don't want to do
um but again it is merely making a
statement about what we think people
should choose not telling anyone what
they need to do and I'm also slightly
surprised that we've been told it's an
unambitious motion whilst then having it
watered down and having
um two of the main points taken out of
it
um and it is it isn't an ambitious
motion we have done very ambitious
motions in the past this one I did
describe in the introduction as low
hanging fruit these are the things that
would be cheap and easy and that Annie
Council really that was taking this
seriously would be doing without having
to be nudged these are quick easy
effective things that we could do and
the dress code
um I have spoken to HR about this there
is no explicit support for
um
addressing appropriately for active
transport or public transport in our
dress code and so it is not at the
moment explicit in there and so yes I'm
glad that there is support for some of
the motion and it is disappointing that
we haven't got a systematic commitment
to using language
um to choosing language that takes this
as seriously as we can and that we're
not going to even try to learn the
lessons from the efficient and Nimble
setting up of the community hubs to see
what we could learn for the climate
crisis thank you thank you
I will now put the amendment to the vote
I think we do need a vote for this one
those in favor of the amendment please
show
just hang on so we know we've got the
numbers
yep thank you hands down and those
against the amendment police show
okay hands down so the amendment has
been carried amendment has been carried
so the amendment becomes a substantive
motion
do we need any further debate on that
many numbers wish to speak
Council Weston
thanks chair just to remind all members
that if they were
um to vote against the substantive
motion they would be voting against the
um going to the range of actions that
are set out in the amended version of
what is now the substantive motion so I
hope that we will see all party support
for that thank you
okay I will now put the substantive
motion to the vote which is the
amendment if you're all understanding
that all those in favor please show
unanimous
yep hands down thank you that has been
carried
motion 8D the next motion on tackling
Health inequalities in Trafford
is to move by Council Slater
do I press some oh no
start pressing modes and stuff thank you
mayor I think it's quite shameful that
in the 21st century and as the sixth
richest economy in the world we're
talking about health inequalities in our
Borough
year on year Health has been improving
in England and life expectancy was
increasing however from 2011 these
improvements have noticeably started to
reduce year on year
Health isn't just about funding care and
supporting for and support for our
residents as the acute end of the system
it's about prevention through access to
decent homes well to paid and secure
work it's about educational
opportunities that are equal for all if
we preventing inequality in health we
improve everyone's life and improve our
economy
we know that the Saudi government along
with our lib Dem colleagues cause
massive inequality in this country from
2010 through to 2015 and then
single-handedly the Tories have
continued to make the least able pay for
their poor handling of this country
we were promised leveling up in 2019 and
yes we've had a pandemic what we knew in
2016 our Public Services were not
capable of sustaining the country if we
had a crisis such as covid-19 as the
government had starved the NHS local
government the police and many other
public services
the lack of resources cannot be blamed
on covid
because it because it's because of
continued underfunding
approximately 11.6 of our naught to 16
year olds in Trafford that's around
5085 of our children
just let that sink in
5085 of our children live in poverty
this is shameful and it's a
responsibility of every one of us to
lift these children out of the situation
and make a real difference to their
lives just because we might not know
them personally doesn't mean that we
shouldn't care and do something about
them
life expectancy at life expectancy for
some Trafford residents is lower than
the national average in some of our
deprived Wards the reality is that our
men are living 9.3 years less and our
women are living 7.4 years less than
other Wars in in Trafford it's an
outrage
the Marmot review of 2020 outlined the
more impoverished a local Authority the
higher mortality rate and this can't
continue
we as a local Authority have a crucial
role to play in reducing inequality
across the borough
equality needs to be that at the heart
of everything that we do
we need leveling up
we need to consider how we meet the six
policy objectives of Marmot so our three
boards that sit under the health and
well-being board have to be at our Focus
to improve Trafford these are our start
well live well and age well boards if we
don't get it right there now
then we're going to see future
Generations left behind
we need real investment from central
government we need leveling up for for
our nation and we need it now
traffic lead Health inequality must be
our prior priority leveling leveling all
will only work if the government invests
new money into our Council to support
our communities I ask you to support the
motion
thank you Council Slater
is the
motion seconded
councilor Taylor would like to come to
the front
thank you mayor
so Michael Marmot uh 2021 report states
that greater Manchester had a 25 higher
covid-19 death rate than England as a
whole
that high death rate contributed to
decline in life expectancy Across The
Wider Northwest and was larger than the
average in England
the report shines a light on the high
levels of avoidable Health inequalities
as a result of long-standing economic
and social inequities existing in
Greater Manchester
High rates of covert mortality have been
driven by poverty those in low paid
insecure employment being unable to
isolate and forced to risk Contracting
covert and bring it home to their
families
children and young people have been
disproportionately harmed by the impacts
of covid and have experienced the most
rapid increases in deteriorating levels
of mental health and unemployment
this pandemic has laid bare and
Amplified the growth inequalities that
exist both in Greater Manchester and in
the country as a whole
but these things are not inevitable
they're a choice they're a societal and
a political choice
so Michael calls for a doubling of
Health Care spending in this region over
the next five years in particular
refunding of local governments who have
been stripped bare in the last decade to
tackle and prevent Health inequalities
but with a country and crisis confronted
with soaring fuel prices labor shortages
price hikes are brutal and heartless
Universal Credit cut which will force
thousands of families further into
poverty having to make the Heat or eat
choices this winter
and this government's Reckless and
deadly mishandling of the pandemic being
roundly condemned by the Health and
Social cares committee Lessons Learned
report that was published yesterday what
is our Prime Minister doing about it
well currently he's sketching in the Sun
at his billionaire mate's mansion in
Marbella
what a dumbing indictment of the
government's leveling of agenda seems
that senior Tories have actually got
formed for escaping to the sun when
faced with a crisis leveling up I think
we need actually some leveling down the
Prime Minister needs to get to grips
with the obscene inequalities that exist
in this country which are taking almost
a decade off the lives of some of the
residents in some parts of this Borough
as the UK emerges from the covid-19
pandemic buildback better has been the
Mantra but we need to build back fairer
collaborative Public Health
interventions involving communities
local Regional national government the
voluntary and business sectors have
really strong evidence to support their
efficacy in addressing Health
inequalities and this should be at the
heart of everything we strive to achieve
in this Borough
we can choose a society while while uh
where life expectancy and quality of
life continues to stall and decline or
we can choose to live in a society which
learns from the lessons of the pandemic
and build back fairer thank you chair
thank you councilor Taylor
any members wishing to speak councilor
Carr
thank you chair
I've worked as a doctor for many years
in Greater Manchester serving deprived
communities sadly I frequently see the
effects of a lifetime of debt
deprivation and health inequalities
it's hard to describe how sad it is to
see people younger than me living in ill
health and even dying often of diseases
that have been contributed to or caused
by poor access to preventative health
strategies
never has this been more obvious than
throughout the covert pandemic when
residents in Greater Manchester and
Trafford were so severely affected by
covid
after seeing whole families die one
after another of covid it is no surprise
to me to see the results of the Marmot
review that showed that death rates were
a quarter higher in Greater Manchester
compared to the rest of England
it is heartbreaking to think that
children in more deprived areas of
Trafford are growing up facing a high
likelihood of a reduced life expectancy
and a life adversely affected by ill
health
improve Public Health spending and a
focus on meeting the objectives from the
Marmot review would allow us to give
children a chance to grow up to have a
healthy future I urge all members to
support this motion
thank you councilor Carr any other
members wishing to speak councilor
Brophy
okay so on behalf of the liberal
Democrat group we are supporting this
motion
since I've been a counselor which is a
couple of decades now we've been talking
about inequalities in Trafford it's not
a new issue we welcome them what review
from 2020 but still poverty is an issue
that's been with us most of this Century
the inequalities in Manchester have been
with us for many decades so it isn't
something new but it does make a
difference about how we tackle it and
the choices that we make I think it's
unhelpful that labor politicians seem to
think there's a monopoly on supporting
tackling poverty it's fundamental to my
parties liberal Democrats that tackling
poverty is there in our in our
constitution our reason for being
I think having worked most of my career
in public health it's also clear that it
isn't easy to tackle poverty it isn't
yet of course we need to change the
economy we need to support local
government all these things need to
happen but poverty starts as some of the
councils are mentioned in the early
years and I'm just going to remind
people of those points so when I worked
on a project which was around tackling
childhood obesity and that is a poverty
related issue
it's about investing in supporting our
parents and investing in communities we
had the sure start centers which I
massively supported because we can't
just tackle this problem overnight we've
got to tackle the fundamentals give
every child the best art in life These
are what the six points create Fair
Employment work for all standards of
living it's not something that just
traffic can do on our own it does create
that political world but I think we just
need to work on this together and we do
support the motion and the covid crisis
has emphasized just how bad it is in
terms of what happens when People's
Health isn't looked after but we also
need to empower people I think starting
with local communities and our democracy
that actually helps if we have a better
engagement and democracy then that's
it's not just Poverty of what people and
have it's about the education and it
starts with the early years and
supporting parents with children under
fives to give everybody a better start
in life thank you
thank you councilor Brophy councilor
Jerome would like to comment
thanks chair
uh traffic greens welcome this motion
and support its aims the Marmot report
is a strong evidential basis for future
Council policy on house
however this Council now resolves to
consider the health inequality impact
and all the decision making
so we wonder whether this would have
changed the administration's voting
pattern on previous motions in this
Council for instance rejecting energy
efficient passive housing on Council
land that would that would eliminate
fuel poverty and Quake create warm
healthy homes
voting against local people adopting 20
mile an hour speed limits in their
communities making roads safer lessening
pollution and encouraging healthier
Lifestyles through walking and cycling
is also watered down divesting from
fossil fuels in our petrol funds putting
pension security at risk for public
workers
the USS Administration has also
and taken far too long on our climate
emergency from November 2018. and also
we put forward a motion on Ubi and this
has been amended away
this would have provided security and
Welfare for Citizens whether they're in
work or out of work
so we do welcome this motion but we
would like to see this Administration go
beyond it in creating a healthier future
for all our residents thank you chair
thank you
Council accordingly put his hand up
First Council accordingly
thanks Mr Mayor
um the only point I wanted to briefly
make is that the uh the motion says that
uh Health inequality is not simply a
matter of Health provision
and I agree with that I agree with
everything that's in the motion but I do
want to emphasize that Health provision
is in there at the moment there's
countless reports going on the important
areas very ill patients get less time
with their GP in deprived areas than the
wealthy areas and I think that's an
important point that we didn't we never
should let go that it's all about
poverty that actually the provision of
Health Services matters and sometimes we
put that at risk by focusing absolutely
on the other things never lose sight of
what what's real and the real there are
issues between the Richer parts of the
UK and the poorer Parts in terms of
health provision and I think it's
important not to lose that and it is
being lost a little bit in the debate I
think thank you thank you cancer
councilor Weston
yeah thanks chair and firstly to council
accordingly's point I think he was a
little generous there when he said
between the rich and poorest parts of
the UK it would be fair to say between
the richest and poorest parts of
Trafford and that is a challenge that we
must face head on as a council
I'm reluctant to address the comments of
councilors Brophy and Jerome because I
think they are trying to be supportive
but I do feel that I can
only take so much lecturing from a
liberal Democrat about reminding us that
they are a party that believes in
tackling poverty when they are of course
the party that enabled austerity in this
country and I will make a very clear a
very clear distinction between our local
liberal Democrats who always made clear
their views albeit in many years
supporting conservative budgets in this
Council and the liberal Democrats
nationally but if it feels that we have
a monopoly on poverty when we speak on
this issue I do not think it is
intentional but it is important to
remember when councilor Brophy describes
herself as a passionate advocate for
sure start centers that it was under her
government's watch because the liberal
Democrats were a party of government
from 2010 to 2015 that thousands of
short start centers were closed that the
bedroom tax
brought Havoc for many in our
communities that people face benefit
sanctions on the altar of austerity an
austerity that has since
been attributed
as a cause of more than 100
000 preventable deaths so I am not
suggesting for a moment that the liberal
Democrats here in this chamber do not
feel passionately about fighting poverty
chair on the contrary I know that all
three of them feel very strongly about
this but I do think we need to remember
that there is so much attempted yellow
washing goes on and the austerity itself
could not have happened without the
liberal Democrats and councilor Brophy
is frantically trying to share
information with councilor newgrass to
rebook this but the public know the
truth here they know austerity couldn't
have happened without the liberal
Democrats selling off their principles
in exchange for ministerial cars and so
I really do appreciate that this is an
issue that you care passionately about
but it is an issue that has arisen as
almost a direct result or certainly
worsened as a direct result of your
party's role in government finally and
briefly to counselor Jerome what I'd say
is that there is always a tension in our
views on this because passive house
standards drive up house prices we know
this so it is a balancing act between
house price and energy price and
actually when you have a housing crisis
that is a debate that we need to have
the pension fund you said we're putting
people's Pension funds at risk but we
know that only sensible divestment which
is the policy of the greater Manchester
pension fund will enable us to divest in
a way that does not put the pensions of
thousands of public sector workers and
retired public sector workers in this
connotation at risk if we want to talk
about tackling poverty deprivation and
inequality surely safeguarding people's
pensions pots it's a relevant
consideration in that and finally on
universal basic income we're described
as washing this motion away on the
contrary we attempted to amend it but
you weren't happy to hear what we had to
say on this issue which is that a
universal basic income is an Noble
Endeavor but it is not targeted and that
a universal basic income therefore is
not necessarily the best use of public
funds I would have welcomed that debate
and of course one of the reasons that is
becoming clear that the greens were so
Keen to have amendments published in
advance is so that if you they don't
agree with an amendment they'll just
wipe it off The Ledger it really is
pathetic because it means that we've not
debated the merits of a minimum income
guarantee which was the position that
the labor Amendment sought to set out a
minimum income guarantee which does
exactly the same as a universal basic
income in terms of providing that safety
net for the poorest and in the very
specific constraints of this motion it
is imperative to recognize that a
minimum income guarantee would do
everything that a universal basic income
does to help the poorest in our society
to tackle that Gap to address the fact
that the richest are getting richer and
the poorest are getting poorer and to
provide that safety net at a reasonable
level for all thank you chair
thank you councilor Western councilor
Blackburn
Mr Mayor
um we all want Health inequalities to be
reduced so that every resident has a
Level Playing Field to quality of life
and there's no need to smoke at me while
some speaking thank you
and within our fine Borough I am
concerned however if a resident does not
want to interact and improve their own
health and it will prove an uphill
battle for us as a Borough I give an
example of my lovely dad who died in Old
Trafford on his allotment at the age of
71. he smoked since he was a soldier in
the Second World War
he tried giving up and it lasts about
three days and he'd start again he
smoked 20 to 30 a day it was an
addiction
he knew he was doing wrong he knew his
effects in his health but he couldn't do
anything about it and he died so he's
become one of those statistics
um a man living in Old Trafford on a
poorly paid job for all his life and he
lived five years after retiring
um it was just something he it wasn't a
stupid man but it was an addiction and
unfortunately there are certain things
that I don't think we're ever going to
overcome and if somebody does not want
help if somebody either drinks too much
and you can't help them or they smoke
too much and somebody else is smirking
at me it doesn't matter I can tell about
my life but it's it's a joke but I think
I think it's very difficult as um as a
local Authority for us to overcome
certain health issues and I wish that we
could deal with every Health inequality
because I think we are decent people and
this is what we want for the people in
our Borough thank you Mr Mayor thank you
Council Blackburn councilor newgrash
like to comment
I just want to comment on the uh what um
Andrew Weston said
I want to remind him if we're going into
history labor crashed the economy
Chancellor Brown
didn't do anything councilor Brown
Chancellor oh Chancellor
and there was the note left at the end
there we're out of money well that was a
situation and can I add that the cuts
that did come because of that were less
than the
um cuts that labor had actually
manifestoed for that election so the we
actually mitigated some of the other
side's worst cuts that were going to be
but it was it was all because labor
crashed the economy thank you I support
the motion by the way
thank you councilman ugrash Council
Robbins like to comment
shh please thank you chair
um I think we've got a little bit of
Peace here uh that would say the least
however
um there's so much in uh looking at the
resolutions of the motion and there's so
much in it there's a it's certainly
eight out of the nine that that we would
100 agree with
um but I have reached out to the leader
as the leader will probably attest uh to
get a minor tweak and it we could
possibly have got it to
um
a universal vote on this but it's all
about scoring a political point and not
about making a universal statement from
the members of Trafford so we won't be
supporting and it's a shame because our
members here would have spoken
eloquently to the motion
um but it seems disingenuous to then not
support the motion so we won't be
supporting the motion but they're
terribly sad because it's been more
about scoring a point rather than
actually making a statement from the
members of Trafford thank you thank you
councilor Evans
leader yes yeah thank you on a point of
personal clarification as per the
Constitution chair I think it's
important that all members understand
exactly what council Reverend's asked me
to do which was to remove one of the
most substantive parts of the motion the
bit that asked his government to reverse
funding Cuts so just so all members are
clear what the conservatives found
acceptable and what they did not thank
you chair thank you anybody else wish to
comment councilor Slater you have the
right to reply
foreign
I don't think I'll be able to speak as
eloquently as Andrew has and made lots
of points but I do want to pick up on a
few points that have been made by
um some of our colleagues in the in the
chambers this evening and the the issues
that were raised by the liberal
Democrats around
um austerity well actually they did
enable austerity and you will find that
naught to 11 year olds in this Borough
have been growing up on under astiracy
because you actually enabled it around
the pension fund divestment the pension
fund is looking to diver divest but
actually they have to protect the money
within there for the people who have
been saving a lot of those people who
will be getting a pension out of the
local government pension fund are really
low paid women workers whose pensions
are around 3 000 pounds a year so
actually the pension fund and what
they've done is they've continued to pay
uh invest in in in to get big returns we
used to invest in tobacco we used to
invest in at interarms we don't do that
anymore we are moving away from
um petroleum and all those other things
we're looking to invest in green things
green
um processes going forward and a green
economy going forward but currently they
can't just take that money out and leave
people who've been paying into the fund
high and dry those people are low paid
and they deserve their pensions intact
and also I I note this the comments from
councilor Blackburn about people need to
take individual responsibility with
individual responsibilities where we've
got to and it's the problems that have
been caused by the Tory government
because they're only interested in
themselves they're not interested in
their communities or or social
conscience
um and I'm really sorry that your father
died at age 73 but we were talking
earlier about men in our ward in our
borrowers dying 10 years earlier than
that so the majority of our men who live
in very poor circumstances are dying at
63 and I know that it's you know it's
very said about your dad but we can't be
blaming people if they become addicted
we need to understand what the root
causes are for those people
and then you know and to say that there
was a note to say um we're out of money
well that's because Parliament with the
agreement of all parties backed bailing
out the banks if I had been there I
wouldn't have bailed out the banks I'd
have left the banks high and dry but we
didn't we bailed out the banks and
that's why there was no money so I would
just like to put that on the record uh
Mr Mayor and I hope that people can
support this motion because I'm sick and
tired of seeing poor people I'm sick and
tired of seeing people on the streets
because nobody is giving a damn around
them we need to do something and we all
need to step up and it's shameful if you
do not support this motion
thank you councils later
I will now put the motion to the vote
all those in favor of the motion please
show
okay hands down
and those against emotion please show
okay thank you hands down
the motion is carried thank you
please my invite the leader to introduce
and move the next motion set out at
eight e
rather counselor Harding is going to
move the motion set out to 80. please
regarding social care funding Council
Harding
thank you
each and every one of you in this room
stood on a doorstep and clapped for
carers last year
I would also guess that each and every
one of you will have had casework that
involved a resident that you represent
not getting the care
that they need when they needed it
you may even have come to me as the
executive member about this or to some
of our very dedicated offices across
Trafford Council
because you were wanted to have found a
solution for your resident because you
will have felt their pain and you will
have known what their families were
experiencing as a result of not getting
what they needed
I recall standing in the council chamber
back in 2019 and telling you the story
of my gran Ali
I recall saying if the care she received
wasn't good enough for her and it wasn't
good enough for your families
that it can never be good enough for any
of the families that we represent in
Trafford
you stood with me then
United in the belief and knowledge
that we all want better for social care
we know the people that we represent
deserve better for social care
so I'm asking you to do the same this
evening
so let us start with the word reform
to put or change into an improved
condition
enforcing or introducing a better method
the statement of Boris Johnson on social
care was not about reform it barely
touches the sides
he said he had a clear plan
there is no plan
the cap on care of 86 000 pounds is not
reform
this is just finishing part two of The
Care Act
and it won't kick in until October 2023
and it's only going to benefit three to
five percent of people who need care
the majority of money pledged to be
raised by the levy will go to the NHS as
a rescue plan
social care again left in the shadows
and of the 3.6 billion raised by the
levy which is regressive by the way only
5.4 billion will come to social care
and half of this will just go on some of
the existing strains that we already
have in the system
social care needs 2.6 billion a year due
to our existing pressures that is just
to stand still
so I'm not going to quote figures at you
anymore I'm not going to do that because
whenever I talk about social care I want
to tell you the story of what social
care really is I'm going to talk about
people because that's what social care
is about
and I'm going to tell you what reform is
not
reform is not a Workforce that deserves
to be underpaid and undervalued
it is not care providers failing and
leaving our residents without care
it is not a huge backlog of AIDS and
adaptations that would enable people to
live independently for longer in their
own home it is not about families and
carers on their knees
it is not about me getting calls about
residents left in bed until 2PM because
demand has outgrown our capacity in this
Borough
it is not about going backwards with
people left in hospital and it is not
about young people preparing for
adulthood with no clear support because
we have a national send crisis
I tell you what reform is
it's a clear Workforce strategy
it's a new employment deal for staff
it's an adult social care minimum wage
it's enhanced training and staff feeling
valued it's development and progression
sustainable funding and not firefighting
I will end by saying that today I was
part of the local government Association
Community wellbeing board where I sit as
a representative
and this is a cross-party group of
politicians all committed to lobbying
this government each and every one of
them conservatives green party members
liberal Democrat labor Independence all
committed and United to Lobby this
government on social care to address the
issues in Social care committed to a
national campaign on social care and
counselor Evans interesting that they
are also committed to reinstating the
public health money
we should be proud to want to do this
and invest in our people
they are members of our communities they
are young people living with a learning
disability with aspirations they are
people getting older but staying well
why would we not want to push for this
there is a huge economic and emotional
risk in us not doing this
so I ask you to stand with me again this
evening and support this motion because
some things are above politics and the
people that we represent are thank you
thank you counselor Harding is the
motion seconded seconded chair reserve
the right thank you thank you any
members wishing to speak
councilor Brophy thank you
so
I'd just like to support the last
comment that um was made by the Mover of
the motion that um these motion these
situations are above politics Public
Health social care we have opportunities
in Greater Manchester in Trafford
because we're actually trying to
integrate Health and Social care in a
way that isn't happening anywhere else
in the country presents us with
opportunities
but people are bringing Party politics
into this so I'm going to too because
what we need the liberal Democrats are
calling for a cross-party solution to
reform of social care
we're also calling for attacks a one
penny to increase it's not popular when
political parties call for increases in
income tax but actually that's because
we're not a party that is here just to
speak for what we think our voters want
to hear we want to try and do the right
thing so we are proposing a penny on
income tax for social care but these
things are going to be difficult to fix
I mean I speak as a care I have three
caring people I care for as an
individual my dad
um his power of attorney my I have two
other members of my family who also have
significant social care it's it is about
increasing funding it is about
supporting our staff and I think we need
to look politically all together all
parties at the choices people make when
they go into employment so right now
the social care that my family member is
supposed to have doesn't happen very
often it's often canceled and the staff
are often not turning up not just
because they're not turning up covid is
impacted on that but it's also the
choices that they're making
they are choosing to work elsewhere
because care whilst it might be a good
career in in terms of like because you
want to do the right thing you want to
care for people it's not a good career
in terms of whether you can afford to
live somewhere whether you can pay the
rent for your house it's not a good
career in terms of what it pays and we
don't pay our carers the right what they
deserve what they should have it's not
just about the pay it's about the
conditions and it's about the support
for that whole sector we just don't give
it adult thought and we haven't planned
ahead in our economy to make enough
carers in the system people are choosing
to work in restaurants and bars and
elsewhere and there's a lot we can do
but we can only tackle this together we
can't tackle it we just sit in traffic
Council making political points we've
got to to work together and do what's
possible because that's what we're all
about here in Trafford working together
support our communities
thank you councilor Brophy anybody else
wishing to speak
no
that's the Western let's go no
um councilor Harding you have the right
to reply some up
thank you mayor um just in response to
councilor Brophy I think I said loud and
clear that I wanted it to be cross-party
I think I couldn't have been any clearer
really and I'm very happy to share with
you the information from the LGA in fact
I would welcome sharing that with the
health scrutiny committee and Shadow
executive member so that we can have a
look at this as a cross-party group of
people so with that in mind I would urge
your members to support the motion
portfolio this evening thank you
thank you councilor Harding
I will now put the motion to the vote
all those in favor please show
yep hands down thank you and those are
games please show
thank you hands down
the motion is carried thank you the
motion is carried
the final motion this evening concerns
voter ID and will be moved by councilor
Denise Weston councilor Weston
thank you mayor I'm delighted to bring
this motion to council as I firmly
believed that this government's plans to
legislate for electors to show An
approved form of ID in order to vote is
a totally unnecessary and extremely
costly change to a democratic system in
a country where public confidence in the
running of Elections is so high
over 2 million people in this country do
not currently have recognizable photo ID
I myself fall into that category I still
have my paper license
and my passport is over a decade out of
date my passport photo it looks like
something from the last Millennium in
fact I don't like flying that's my
choice
but there are so many other people who
will be in the same position
you are a parent on a low-income
struggling on a daily basis to get by in
these austere times often reliant on
food banks to feed your family or a
pensioner living on a fixed income and
concerned about how you are going to
heat your home in the winter months for
these and indeed for many other people
in this country car ownership and
holidays abroad are simply unaffordable
luxuries and the need for obtaining or
renewing a driving license or passport
both of which cost money to do is just
not a priority for anyone living on a
limited budget
and whilst there are plans in place for
local authorities to provide a voter
card free of charge where an elector
does not have one of the approved forms
of photo identification
I fear that this will cause
administrative chaos and lead to many
electors being unable to vote due to
delays in processing applications no
matter how well these changes are
publicized there will be many people who
don't realize until it's too late to act
on this
we pride ourselves on being a free
country a democracy where currently
everyone over the age of 18 has the
right to vote the right to have their
voice heard and counted this
government's proposed changes will
result in a proportion of the electorate
being disenfranchised with marginalized
communities those with protected
characteristics as well as those less
well-off most likely to be impacted I
feel strongly that this would be a
retrograde step for democracy and would
urge all members to support this motion
thank you thank you councilor Weston
um
councilor Proctor is going to second the
motion councilor Proctor
um I'm happy to support this motion
against this election bill which will
mean if introduced that millions of
Voters could be disenfranchised under
the discriminatory plans that will force
people to carry identification to cast a
ballot between elections
it's not unfair to say that these
sweeping changes are tantamount to U.S
republican-style voter suppression and
are only being introduced to give them
electoral advantage to the conservatives
the reason why we oppose this are set
out in detail in the motion as Council
Weston has already explained very well
the government main argument in this
year's queen speech in favor of voter ID
is that he would make elections more
secure by cracking down on in-person
voter fraud
the reality however is that voter fraud
is virtually non-existent
and has been downplayed by the Electoral
commission which has said that the UK
has low levels of proven electoral fraud
in 2019 there was just one conviction
and one police caution for impersonating
another voter this is just two cases in
47 million registered electors
so this is an unnecessary solution to a
problem that barely exists
the impact of this however without many
voters will be to Sun franchise from
this requirement
various pilots and voted ID ranging from
people simply having to present polling
cards to mandatory voted documents such
as passports or driving license took
place in a series of English council
districts at local elections in 2018 and
19. with over 1100 voters turned away in
pollen stations so this is clear
evidence that it does have an impact
I set out in the motion we also know
that the research from the cabinet
office found that more than two million
people do not have recognized
photographic ID with women are
considering less likely than men and
black people can can just simply less
likely than white people to have driving
licenses
while certain ethnic groups are more or
less likely to have they've done
leveraged to have a passport
so these groups will be
disproportionately affected by this
proposal
yes under the plan's electors can apply
for voltrac a voter card but the reality
of this that many people won't do this
and therefore be prevented from voting
we should in reality be encouraging more
people to vote rather than putting in
place these are necessary and
discriminated barriers
there's no ground solve of General
opinion for this either with public
confidence in the running of Elections
as His Highest since 2012.
do the negative impact of this proposal
is the cost
which will be 40 million or even more
over the next decade this will include
Millions on new polling cards necessary
for voter identification and production
of plastic voter cards for those who
don't have suitable identification
especially at a time when the public
finances are particularly stretched this
is a waste of taxpayers money which
could be avoided
I left for urge counselors to vote in
favor of this motion and against the
introduction of voter ID for the many
reasons we have outlined it tonight
as the Electoral form reforms scientists
said these plans could lead to
disfantagement of an industrial scale
and this is something that this Council
should oppose in anywhere we can thank
you mayor thank you councilor Proctor
any members wish to speak councilor
Minis
thank you chair
um so I think that if we're going to
make change to systems that we already
have they've got to be evidence-based
because otherwise you know
we start doing some very silly things
evidence of voter ID the idea is that
it's voter suppression
it's not going to help democracy it's
going to stop it
all of us that have done telling polling
stations in the rain and the Sunshine
hopefully
know that more than 10 people per
polling station arrive that day on that
polling day and they don't have their
polling card
right and I've been guilty of this
turning up a polling station myself
without the polling card because I'm
still about box voter
now in 2019 we had lots of Elections I'm
sure we all remember where the locals
where the general election in December
we had the Euros we had mayoral pccs uh
by-elections both local and
parliamentary in all of those elections
do you know how many cases there were of
people thinking there's been electoral
flawed fraud sorry and that's 595.
investigated
four convictions in that year four
so lots of Elections
you know how many voters there are is
this a problem clearly it isn't a
problem is it electoral fraud is not a
thing yeah when something's not a thing
we don't need to change something and
make it worse do we
so the options for ID passport not
everyone has one certainly not one in
date I don't have one in date currently
a driving license I do have one of those
but not everyone does
blue badge if you're a disabled person
with the blue badge
proof of age standards scheme the pass
thing
the then we have some travel passes
so and then we have this catch-all thing
at the end which is that you can get a
free card from your Council
um so you've got to remember to take
that with you like you've got to
remember you know we're suggesting
you've got a member of your polling card
you've got to remember take this with
you to the polling station and do not
think that this free card from the
council it comes at a cost to the
council which is always underfunded so
when you don't have a problem why would
you create a problem
um I don't understand why anyone would
create a problem when the problem
doesn't exist and the problem you're
trying to solve isn't there it's not a
thing so
I'm supportive of this motion but I
thought I'd give you the reasons but
thank you very much
thank you councilor minis councilor
Jerome
thanks chair I agree with everything
that's that's been said so far and as
councils we we kind of work really hard
to make our electors voices heard and
those that we strive most hardly to
reach will be the ones that will lose
out so I welcome this uh motion from
from the labor party but over the the
last few weeks it's been even more
encouraging to see the labor party
moving to um
revise and make our electoral system
even even better and that labor Party
Conference um not long ago 80 of rank
file members uh supported PR
and I went on to laborlist.org
um and to quote Elliot Chapel from there
he says the labor party membership is
United behind the drive to make votes
count for all it's unsustainable for a
party to be a have policy or odds with
the values of its members
our campaign will continue we are
determined labor must go forward to the
next general election with a firm
promise that it was support PR replace
our rotten electoral system and mend our
broken democracy so we'll be supporting
this motion tonight because it is voter
suppression and would be encouraging
labor also to maybe bring up a PR Motion
in the future thanks chair
thank you councilor Jerome
um Council accordingly please
thank you mayor Walsh
um I thought it was pretty shabby in the
last motion that the Tories didn't speak
to a motion that they weren't voting for
that were voting against and it looks
like they're going to do the same on
this one I think that's pretty shabby
actually because this this this is a
a policy introduced by the Tory party I
I as has been explained to suppress
votes but it surprises me
um here
it surprises me well it wasn't very
quick it was it was after mine and I was
slow and I waited and waited
um but it surprises me because actually
I'm not convinced that in Trafford for
instance that the impact will be
entirely on uh again in favor of the
Tories a lot of elderly people also do
not have this these uh eye forms of ID
um you you are going to be upset in your
own vote
um and every voter that gets upset
usually tells their their neighbor that
they weren't allowed to vote you are
going to have a comeback on this I'm
telling you this is not right this is
that you should Vote for This motion and
I hope you will because actually what
it's about is giving people the right to
vote it's something precious in this
country and you don't mess about with it
and your party is doing some dangerous
stuff at the moment and this is one of
those so I urge you when you do speak to
be supporting the motion thank you
thank you councilor accordingly um
I've got two more speakers I want to
limit that to two minutes I need to
finish the business this evening
councilor Taylor
thank you Matt I'll keep this really
really brief
let's just call out the elections bill
for exactly what it is what it is is
apply by the conservative party to
suppress a vote to exclude probably
larger poorer deprived people who are
less likely to vote conservative
probably more likely to vote labor and
to deter them from voting that is the
top and bottom of this bill it is
oppressive it is discriminatory and this
is dealing with a non-existent problem
of voter fraud and it is completely
undemocratic and unnecessary let's call
a spade a spade that's what it's about
thank you councilor Taylor councilor
newgrass you have two minutes
on to Echo what's gone before
um especially Council Proctor he
actually everything I wrote down here
you you said it is naked voter
suppression so suppression worthy of
Trump's alt-right
it's unnecessary costly and a blatant
attempt to
disenfranchise our voters
um of of all Hues but this is
disenfranchisement uh so I'm going to
vote for this motion and I would love to
hear what councilor Evans has to say
thank you councilor newgrash councilor
Myers please
uh what I would say is that electoral
Ford in some parts of uh the the United
Kingdom has been a serious problem in
the past
and in fact it was a labor government
that introduced the 2003 act in Northern
Ireland where in the ardoin area in
particular and also in parts of South
armah photo intimidation was very very
common and people were impersonating
other people
uh gerrymandering if you like and that's
where I suppose the expression comes
from I think it's a very important
measure we do make sure that people who
are entitled to vote vote and I agree
with that point and every every member
of our party would agree with that point
but we've got to make sure that people
who aren't entitled to vote or want to
vote more than once do not vote and that
is what this uh this measure is all
about
thank you Mr sorry thank you mayor
okay now we really are running late on
this and I need to give councilor
Western Council Denise Western the right
to reply councilor Blackburn you go
first
everybody who is over pensionable age
retirement pension
can apply for their free bus pass funded
by Her Majesty's governments and
obviously our local Council costs one
photograph so you don't have to be poor
and have no ID
and I've got my old age pensioner ID
here so I can get any on any bus in
Greater Manchester thank you
thank you Council Blackburn councilor
Morgan can you be brief please but
succinct thank you um I just want to
quote someone
um so we cannot allow the electorate to
become disillusioned with the political
process because they may feel the
elections are not fair if there is a
high threat of electoral abuse the
Democratic process will be under threat
that's Lord most in the Lord privy sale
under Tony Blair
um 19 years ago in 2002 so I hope in her
summary councilor Weston explains why
labor imposed this on the people of
North Northern Ireland and to quote
councilor Proctor if millions of people
are going to be disenfranchised thank
you Mr Mayor thank you councilor Morgan
councilor Denise Weston you have the
right to reply
sorry hang on hang on
a leader wants to speak
yeah thanks chair very briefly I I
promise because I wouldn't want to uh
hold of all people counselors in east
west and up in uh her opportunity to to
sum this up but I may lead the council
but she is very much in charge as I'm
sure most of you know however
um councilman Morgan has just
answered councilor Myers answered
councilor Morgan's question
this is about responding to an issue
that doesn't exist or barely exists at
present but the issue in Northern
Ireland was a significant significant
problem of voter
intimidation I don't understand how you
can say you did it here when you had no
reason to do so when councilman says
there was a reason or you're now arguing
that there's a reason when the
statistics don't back you up look the
question here is about priorities we've
got a government that last week cut
Universal Credit we've got rape
convictions at an all-time low we've got
people using food banks we're still
coming out of a global pandemic and what
is this Tory government trying to
prioritize a laughably entitled
elections Integrity Bill designed simply
to suppress those least likely to vote
for them it's disgrace Mr Mayor and
whatever councilor Morgan says it's
entirely separate to Northern Ireland
for the very reasons his own colleague
Ward colleague no less neatly set out
thank you chair thank you councilor
Weston councilor Denise Weston you have
the right to reply
is this working yeah thank you mayor um
I don't really have much to add to that
I'm very disappointed
um that the conservative group
don't fear they're able to support this
motion but thank you to the liberal
Democrats and to the green speakers who
are happy to support thank you thank you
councilor Weston I will now put the
motion to the vote
those in favor of the motion police show
okay hands down thank you and those
against the motion please show
okay I think we've got the numbers hands
down that motion has been carried that
motion has been carried thank you
everybody
um that is the end of this meeting I
thank you for your attendance and hope
you enjoy the rest of your evening thank
you everybody and please keep safe